Today we are trying out something a bit more extreme.
We are playing table tennis in the middle of this lake!
Alright, here begins our building process.
Here is the raft.
It's going to be about 6.7 meters long.
Yeah, it's going to be a quite big raft.
Let's start building!
So we have four of these
Floating things
And now we are going to connect the first two.
Okay, and this is our construction manager
Pekka
Nice to meet you!
He has got it all planned out
And we trust that his measurements are correct!
And helping us here is Patrik
This is going to be the middle part now.
Coming next.
Miikka is trying to learn how to use this tool.
Maybe we should start a construction YouTube channel.
Maybe!
I like "Building Pongfinity"
So we have to pull it a bit more towards the lake
So that we get some more space to build it over there.
Further, further!
This is the length.
C'mon!
Faster, faster!
Let's go, let's go!
This is it.
This thing is big.
Does it matter if it gets wet?
Remember that we are going to take it in the middle of the lake!
That was a stupid question!
Starting to look like something!
How are you going to film from there?
You are going to film!
I'm just going for a row! Bye!
Emil is trying to run away
I will row around the island!
We are out here in the middle of a lake building a raft
Just so that we can get videos for you
So do us a favor and hit subscribe!
Do it now!
It floats!
Okay so we have started building the floor
Otto and Pekka are there
I think we are going to run out of wood
I have been doing this for like 15 minutes now
I know what I'm doing!
Or no.
This is going to be our new training hall
Outside training hall!
So we are going to start training here in the middle of the lake!
I think we are wrapping things up here
We are going to continue tomorrow finishing the raft.
Okay it's day 2 of building the raft
There it is
It's starting to look okay!
Let's finish this thing!
So we are sort of using whatever we find
How is the grip?
It's good!
With these sandals the grip is not the best.
I hope I will not end on the blooper section.
Jackpot-Patrik
Soon it's like crack!
And everybody is in the water!
Almost.
Soon.
Soon it's going to be.
Coming up right after this!
Then we put a commercial break here.
Four out of four.
We are drilling the supports onto the raft
So that the table won't wobble around.
So they look like that.
If there is some people seeing us in the middle of the lake
What are they going to think?
A table tennis table on raft in the middle of a lake?
The final piece of the puzzle.
Yeah
Guys
There we go!
The raft is ready!
Now take a look at that!
It's quite good
Full speed ahead!
Almost impossible!
Wow!
Almost fell over!
Blooper material!
Picking up the balls.
This is so incredible to be here
Straight on the GoPro!
Looking good Emil!
Thank you
What a backhand!
First-person GoPro playing
In the middle of a lake.
C'mon! We can beat Otto!
Almost.
Well, that was a pretty good point!
I can't wait to play on this
Pretty nice!
The landscape is so incredible here!
Okay now the raft is actually under water!
We have a bit of a flood situation!
I don't think it's a problem.
This is how you train footwork on a Summer holiday!
Sorry!
Okay, so we are going to do a Pongfinity diving shot tournament.
Vote on the comments whose dive is the best!
I'm going to try to do a between the legs
I will try to get it on table
Emil is the first one to go!
Ready, set, go!
That wasn't too bad actually!
It was a good try!
C'mon!
Ready, set, go!
I was expecting you to jump far!
My fault.
That was completely your fault!
That was close!
It's a bit tiring to swim and
Jump onboard again
And jump out again
I'm scared!
Ready, set go!
Atleast you have to give style points for it!
C'mon Emil!
The worst serving ever!
That was close!
Not bad Michael!
Ok, last try!
That was so close! Really close!
Now we will see what the Sensei can do!
Ready, set, go!
That was really close!
A stylish jump though!
It was just one meter too short
Pretty good!
That's how you do it!
You still got three left!
I can do a better one
It wasn't a roller!
He wanted to make it deep!
He tried to hit me!
Oliver the sea lion
It won't take long until Otto has picked up all the balls!
Here he comes
You are welcome!
Thank you!
Alright guys, I think it's time to take the raft back home!
Remember to subscribe!
And watch our previous episodes there!
Until next time!